salut aujourd'hui je jouais à la valette
du var en fait à l'espace belle je sais
plus quoi on vient de terminer voilà
comme vous pouvez le constater les gars
sont en train de ranger le matériel et
surtout jeu j'ai eu de la visite peut
pas vous le cacher j'ai eu de la visite
je vous fait voir attention c'est cédric
bonjour et là tu es mon ami mais cédric
c'est le mari aux petits copains parce
que c'est le cédric c'est le petit
copain d'héloïse et tout le monde sait
qui est le neveu connais pas ces gens
fabien mais s'ils voulaient connaîtriez
si vous lisiez plus régulièrement les
commentaires du mental blog parce que et
l'oif des abonnés à la chaîne
rien que ça veut dire toi quévillon je
sais je vous fait voir un truc je veux
les faire voir sait pas trop si non vous
fait voir regarder il a de jolis
tatouage magnifique sur le coup tandis
que d'un côté oui juste ici je voulais
refait voir un coup écoute je me donne
une idée si tu me permet j'aimerais
mentaliser ton chéri
alors si tu pouvais faire en sorte
qu'ils l'esprit traîner ses slips en
fait s'il te plaît aux questions quand
même ça veut dire un mot ou plusieurs
mots c'est un mot un mot qui a été cette
fois choisi
c'est ça qui me répond sincèrement
est-ce que
est-ce que ça revient avec la
personnalité oui d'accord et c'est un
lien avec mon vécu
c'est ça ok et c'était une clé que tu
veux pas oublier ok vous marquez dans ta
pensée ça ok ça va en fait je pense à un
mot relativement court en fait c'est ça
je l'écris l'a fait voir à vous est ce
que tu peux me dire ce que veut dire ce
premier tatouage sajan software et adobe
air sage sachez que j'ai s'agit du
processus car c'est un fait bon tu
savais que j'allais faire mentaliser
aubin non mais un petit film merci
d'être venus découvrir un spectacle
merci à toi cette ville d'antibes au
réel ça vous a plu c'est une énorme
bêtise importe ils ont osé passer de la
chaîne youtube au spectacle faites comme
moi vous pouvez oser
allez-y je tairai qui s'en mêle ici
c'est énorme qui sans moi je croi pas
tros cool et puis au final le fait c'est
ici
en direct c'est non allez-y pourrait
avoir les amis merci merci abonnez-vous
à la chaîne youtube c'est très important
vous pouvez aussi me venir me voir un
spectacle vous pouvez les commenter
comme héloïse et après on peut discuter
abonnez-vous à la chesnaie rendez vous
demain à 17 heures pour le prochain
mentale blog ciao